Bitte schön. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Senola Haydn. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistentin der Städtik und würde gerne mit denen das aufmörmige Gespräch hören.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden? Ja, wenn Sie mir helfen können Herr Doktor, dann bin ich
ja zufrieden, ja. Okay, nun frage ich ganz kurz zu Ihrer Person.
Nach, dann höre ich Ihren Bescheid so. Okay? Ja. Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße Joachim Schläfer.
Joachim? Joachim? Ja. Schläfer. Schläfer? Ja, wie jemand der schläft. S-C-H-L-E, also A-Umlaut, F-E-R.
F-E-R. Okay. Herr Schläfer. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 47 Jahre. 47. Wann sind Sie genaue Gebore?
Am 17., 4. 1975. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie? 1 Meter 83 steht in meinem Pass. 83. Okay. Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, so 90 Kilo ungefähr. 90? Okay Herr Schläfer. Was für Sie ist so, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe so starke Schmerzen, so in der rechten Seite, also die sind wirklich stark, also gerade, das kommt so krampfartig zwischendurch,
dann kann ich kaum noch Luft bekommen, ja, also so stark sind diese Schmerzen und das strahlt also auch in die Leiste rein und auch so bis in die Genitalgegend.
Und ja, seit heute Morgen habe ich tatsächlich auch so Schmerzen, wenn ich Wasser lassen muss und ich muss auch ständig laufen, ja, also da kommt immer so ein ganz kleines bisschen.
Und ich habe auch gesehen, das sieht irgendwie blutig aus. Und weil ich solche Schmerzen habe, ich glaube, das hängt damit zusammen,
habe ich mich tatsächlich schon einmal übergeben in so einem Krampf, ja, weil die Schmerzen so enorm waren, ja.
Ich versuche dann immer irgendwo eine andere Position einzunehmen, aber die Schmerzen sind wirklich sehr heftig.
Okay, Herr Schlefer, einen Moment bitte.
Wo sind die Genitalgegend Schmerzen? Sie haben rechte Seite gesagt.
Ja, so unterbauch oder?
Bitte?
Rechten unterbauch oder flanken wir rein.
Nein, wir arbeiten oben so bis in den Rücken rein.
Rücken.
Ja, Teil hier rum so ungefähr.
Okay, die Schmerzen strahlen in die Leistengegend und Genitalgegend.
Ja, genau.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das hatte ich vielleicht schon heute Morgen angefangen, aber seit zwei Stunden ist es wirklich so heftig, dass ich gesagt habe, ich muss jetzt zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen haben.
Ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen oder war Ihnen über?
Ja, ich habe die gesagt, ich habe mich einmal übergeben, ne?
Einmal übergeben, okay.
Ich denke mal, das hängt mit den Schmerzen zusammen, ja, weil das dann irgendwie zu viel war.
Wie sagt das?
Er brach eine Auslösung.
Ja, das ist ein unverdauertes Essen.
Also, wie so gelbliche stinkende Brühe, ja.
Okay, verstanden.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie das bereit?
Nein, das hängt mit einmal an, ganz plötzlich.
Okay, ganz plötzlich angefangen.
Aber Sie wissen keinen Auslöser.
Hatten Sie früher schon mal eine Schmerz?
Nein, kann ich mir jetzt nicht, kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass ich so etwas schonmal hatte.
Okay, fühlst du dich fieberig?
Fieberig, habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber könnte sein, aber ich weiß es definitiv nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Schwerfrust oder schwitz sind Sie über?
Schwitz sind Sie übermäßig?
Schwitzen?
Nein, das waren Sie in der Nacht oder so.
Eigentlich habe ich jetzt nicht mehr geschwitzt.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lehnt oder versteckt, z.B. bei der Bewegung oder beim Messen?
Ja, wenn so eine Kramfelle kommt, dann krümme ich mich halt so zusammen,
dann habe ich den Eindruck, dass es ein bisschen besser wird, dass ich es besser aushalten kann.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch Einbildung, ja.
Okay, denken Sie, dass die Schmerzen mit dem Messen verbunden sind?
Mit dem Essen?
Ja.
Ganz bestimmt nicht, nein.
Okay, und Sie haben Luftnot, Sie haben gesagt, haben Sie Luftnot oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Okay, Sie können ganz gut Luftbecken haben, richtig?
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Gusten oder?
Ach, nicht.
Brustschmerzen, Rückenschmerzen?
Na ja, also da an der Seite, das tut schon weh, ja, da wo das ausgeht, ja, das ist so ein mittlerer Rücken rechts, ja.
Da habe ich schon richtig heftige Schmerzen, ja, da zieht das so richtig rein, ja.
Okay, können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sie sind eher dumm, stetschend, sichend oder brennend?
Ich denke mal, dumpf, dumpf, aber auch brennend, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Und eben in so Wellen, ne?
Dass das so ganz toll kommt.
Wellen, vor mir, meine ich.
Okay, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Also da würde ich jetzt schon sagen, die sind bestimmt bei 8.
8, okay.
Möchten Sie eine Schmerzmittel oder können Sie am Ende des Gesprächs aufseiten?
Ja, das wird ja jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauern, ich habe ja auch schon versucht, ein Ibuprofen zu nehmen, aber das hat irgendwie nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Sie haben, wulut, im Rin, bemerkt, das haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, das war so ein bisschen rot verfärbt, ja.
Okay, wann haben Sie das bemerkt? Heute Morgen mit der Schmerzen oder?
Ja, das, ich glaube, heute, ja, heute Morgen war das, ja.
Okay.
Verstärken Sie die Schmerzen, weiter Bewegung, Treppensteigen oder?
Ja, ich bin jetzt ja nicht mehr viel gelaufen, ich konnte mich ja kaum rühren vor Schmerzen.
Aber ich denke mal, dass es schon, dass ich froh bin, wenn ich sitzen kann und mich so ein bisschen zusammen gründen kann.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden?
Ja, ja.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig zum Beispiel?
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig?
Nein, Schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Okay.
Okay, sonst gehe ich zu allgemein über Fragen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, normalerweise schon, heute Nacht habe ich tatsächlich nicht gut geschlafen.
Wegen der Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, irgendwie hat sich das schon so ein bisschen angebahnt, wohl ja.
Da war das aber noch nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der Sache schon mal ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich glaube, ich bin immer das Gleiche, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise nicht, auch jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Coronasche oder wiechte,
krankungen von denen ihr wissen solltet?
Wir sind beispielsweise krankheit, herzkrankheit oder abkrankheiten?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Das hat man so vor vier Jahren festgestellt.
Seit vier Jahren?
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck ein?
Ich nehme einen Dilltia 10.
Wie bitte?
Dilltia 10.
Kennen Sie die Dosis von Dilltia?
Ja, ich meine, es steht 90 drauf.
Dann nehme ich eine morgen und eine ab.
90 Milligramm, Sie haben gesagt.
Okay, morgens und abends.
Okay, gibt es noch weitere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, das sind nicht so richtig chronische Erkrankungen.
Durch die Arbeit habe ich eine Sehnenentschaltung im rechten Arm.
Das will überhaupt nicht weggehen,
weil ich viel mit den Händen arbeite.
Da nehme ich nach Feierabend ein Dicklofenacksalbe drauf.
Manchmal nehme ich dann auch eben Novolgientropfen
gegen die Schmerzen.
Nehmen Sie diese Medikamente, Dicklofenack und Novolgientropfen,
bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig?
Ja, bei Bedarf, wenn es wie so.
Sie haben Armrecht und Arm gesagt.
Was meine Sie damit? Armrecht und Handgelenk?
Ja, also Unterarm.
Genau.
Okay, und gibt es noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Ja, das werden Sie sehen.
Ich arbeite halt in meiner Bäckerei
und ich habe mir gestern eine Verbrennung dazu gezogen,
weil ich gegen einen heißen Blech gekommen bin.
Das passiert schon mal in meinem Beruf.
Wann ist das passiert?
Das war gestern. Gestern.
Gestern morgens früh.
Wie wurden Sie gestern behandelt?
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Das habe ich selber gemacht.
Ja, das macht sich selber mal wieder.
Ein bisschen gekühlt.
Okay, verstanden.
Und gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Sonst bin ich halt zum Glück gesund.
Okay, sehr gut.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, noch nie. Nicht mal als Kind.
Nein, noch gar nicht.
Herr Schäfer, Sie sind in nächster Zeit im Krankenhaus gewesen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Eine Routine, noch eine Routine Frage.
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Haus noch?
Nein, schon lange nicht.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Coronavirus und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, ich habe alle Impfungen bekommen und jetzt tatsächlich auch alle Corona-Impfungen bekommen.
Herr Schäfer, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie wild hier sind.
Und regelmäßig.
Und benutzen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie oder umfährte?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Ich muss sehr aufpassen mit Westpin.
Das ist natürlich gefährlich in meinem Beruf.
Bei Westpin-Stichen reagiere ich sehr.
Und ich habe auch tatsächlich eine Laktoseentoleranz.
Schritt für Schritt gehen wir, Herr Schäfer.
Wie heißt sich Ihre Westpistich Allergie?
Ja, also da kriege ich dann tatsächlich so ein rotes Gesicht.
Und da habe ich auch einmal fast keine Luft mehr bekommen.
Also das war ein bisschen gefährlich, da muss ich tatsächlich aufpassen.
Und wie setzt sich die Laktoseentoleranz?
Ja, das, was man da so hat, dass man Blähungen und Durchfall hat.
Aber dadurch, dass ich das eigentlich vermeide und vernünftig esse,
habe ich damit kaum noch Probleme seit ich das weiß.
Okay, verstanden.
Und konzentriert Sie, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, seit 5 Jahren rauche ich zum Glück nicht mehr.
Bin ich sehr stolz, aber davor habe ich tatsächlich viele geraucht, ja.
Wie viele Jahre lang?
Ja, 20 Jahre, gut 20 Jahre habe ich auch nicht geraucht, ja.
Eine Schattel plus ein Tag.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Okay, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol, also ich trinke 2-3 Bier am Abend nach der Arbeit,
so vom Schlafengeben.
Ja, das brauche ich wohl.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist auch eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Und gibt es eine ganz kronische oder wichtige Erkrankung in Ihrer Familie?
Ja, also mein Vater, der ist schon ziemlich mitgenommen,
der hat so eine Gefäßerkrankung,
dass er durch Blutungsstörung hat in den Beinen
und der hat da auch eine offene Stelle
und das will überhaupt nicht zuheilen
und dem haben Sie tatsächlich auch schon eine Großzehe amputiert, ja.
Ist gut bereit.
Okay, und bei der Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund,
die hat so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Wirbelsäule,
dass sie so eine Verkrummung hat.
Okay.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, der, lassen Sie mich überlegen, der ist so 72.
72.
Okay.
Und wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Die ist 70.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, sind Sie 3 High Ratens?
Ja, ich bin noch für High Rate, lebe aber alleine.
Ich lebe getrennt von meiner Frau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben 3 Kinder, die leben bei Ihrer Mutter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Ja, gesund, okay, sehr gut.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie in einer Begräufe arbeiten.
Ja, das ist meine eigene Firma, ich bin selbstständig.
Selbstständig, okay.
Ja, aber ich arbeite immer noch in der Firma mit, also auch in der Backstube.
Insofern, ja.
Ja, das ist klar, da muss man schon gucken, dass alles klappt
und dass alles zur richtigen Zeit fertig ist.
Da ist zwar auch viel Routine, aber ja, da geht es schon ziemlich rund.
Okay, verstanden, Herr Schlepper.
Ich habe alles gefragt, was ich brauche.
Möchtest du Ihnen noch etwas hinzufügen oder etwas fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich jetzt natürlich, wo kommen diese wahnsinnigen Schmerzen her
und was kann man dagegen machen?
Ja, Herr Schlepper, zuerst muss ich körperlich untersuchen
und dann einige Labo-Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dafür werde ich Ihnen das Blut abnehmen
und dann können wir ja widersprechen, okay?
Ja, das ist gut, okay.
Sehr schön.
Okay, hat doch jemand sagen an Herrn Schlepper
oder an meinen Doktor?
Niemand will, was ist?
Frau Wiever, haben Sie mir gesagt, ich konnte nicht genau...
Ich habe gefragt, ob jemand von den Kollegen fragt.
Okay, okay.
Hat aber keiner.
Ist alles dran gekommen?
Ja.
Doch, kommt was?
Keine Frage.
Das ist sehr gut.
Ja, das stimmt wirklich.
Wann haben Sie die Prüfung?
Am Samstag, am 6.00 Uhr.
Ja.
Okay, wollen Sie schon präsentieren
oder wollen Sie noch eben...
Ja, ich möchte präsentieren,
aber ich brauche eines, zwei, drei Minuten.
Okay, gut.
Die Frage, die eben kam, habe ich bestätigt.
Habe ich gesagt, haben Sie vielleicht nicht gehört,
da war eine schriftliche Frage.
Brennen beim Wasserlassen, hat er gesagt.
Haben Sie den Fall schon mal gehört, Dr. Gründus?
Ja, wir haben uns zusammen schon gemacht, diese Patiente.
Ja, am 4.01. ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben.
Ja, ich habe eine Bericht geschrieben.
Ja, das war Dr. Mimet.
Dr. Mimet hat den gemacht damals.
Ich nehme unser Bremer-Host sozusagen, dass er das war.
Der treu und brav immer noch unser Host ist, ja, unser Offizieller.
Das ist ja wirklich...
Ja, sehr nett.
Haben Sie von dem was gehört mal?
Was ist das?
Diese Patienten im Teil der gleichen Patienten,
Breiterweg, Frau Breiterweg.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Stimmt, die haben wir zusammen gemacht.
Ja, zusammen gemacht.
Ja, ich erinnere mich, Frau Breiterweg.
Ja, gut.
Aber nee, haben Sie von Dr. Mimet noch mal was gehört?
Was er jetzt macht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie wissen nicht, okay, ja.
Ja, ich finde das immer, ja.
Man geht ja ein Stück Weg zusammen,
man geht mit einmal ab, ja, dann weiß man nicht mehr.
Und dann denke ich immer, ja, vielleicht gehe ich irgendwann mal zum Arzt
und dann sitzt einer von Ihnen da.
Wer weiß, wie die Wege so gehen, ja.
Wie viel Zeit haben Sie in der Prüfung zwischen
Aufnahme und Präsentation?
Haben Sie ein paar Minuten zwischendurch?
In der realen Prüfung.
Hat man da auch Zeit zwischendurch?
20 Minuten.
20 Minuten sogar?
Ja, da kann man ja auch viel machen.
Sie haben diese Zeit zwischendurch zwei Teile gefragt.
Ja, genau, zwischen den beiden Teilen.
Ja, normalerweise in München, nach der ersten Teil,
gibt es keine Lücke, aber schreiben wir erst erst einen.
Ah, okay.
Gut, und mit dem Arzt-Riff kann man dann auch gut präsentieren, ja.
Ja, ja.
Ein bisschen denken.
Das ist immer gut, ja.
Nach fünf Minuten, um die Eva machen wir euch das.
Ah, ja.
Und dürfen Sie am PC schreiben, oder müssen Sie von Hand schreiben?
Hand schreiben.
Vorhand, ne?
Ja.
Ich habe das schon mal gehört, dass jemand,
der einen Prüfer sich über die Handschrift beschwert hat.
Weil, ja, wenn es dann schnell geht,
ja, und die Diogeneration, die können ja überhaupt nicht mehr gut schreiben.
Die haben alles mit dem Computer gemacht, ihr Leben lang.
Und da ist das mit der Handschrift tatsächlich so ein Problem.
Ja.
So, Herr Doktor, kann es losgehen.
Ja, okay.
Guten Tag Frau Oberersten, haben Sie Kurse seit für mich.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Okay, danke.
Herr Joachim Schlepper ist ein 47-jähriger Patient.
Patient?
Patient.
Da sieht bei uns seit gestern bestehender krankartiger Schmerzen
im mittleren Bauch, Rex, mit Ausstrahlung in die Genitalien
und rechte Leistung gegend.
Und Erbeschreibere Schmerzen als dumpf und als dumpf brennend,
sowie allen Formen.
Und Schmerzen würden bei acht von zehn auf einer Schmerzskala
bereitet.
Und der Patient hat gegend Schmerzen
in den Profen angenommen, aber das hat ihn nicht geholfen.
Und als begleitende Zymtome, seitdem Patienten
Polikusserie und Hematurie sowie MEZ aufgefallen.
Und das war jetzt der Patient, das Schmerzen
in den Stasis hat geschimpft.
Und er hat sich einmal über Erbrochen,
das Erbrochen war, essen lässt.
Okay.
Und Bekürzte von MEZ sagt, stressbedingte Zymtome,
Anfolgerkranken gab er an,
Anfolgernde, Arterielle, Vertonis, Alphe,
die mit Diltezem, 90 mg, 2 Maltecklik,
behandelt wurde.
Und Tendovoginitis, am rechten Handgelenk,
die Diktofonaxalbe und Novagin gelegen blick,
behandelt wurde.
Und der Patient hatte gegestern eine Verbrennung
bei der Arbeit, die selbst beantut hat.
Okay. Also nicht so schlimm.
Ja, es ist jetzt noch nicht so schlimm.
Bei Patienten ist keine Operation und keine Krankenhaus
aufwendig.
Und er ist vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten
und Corona-Bürüs.
Der Patient reagiert allergisch auf Westenstich.
Westenstich.
Westenstich, ja.
Rotes Gesicht kann man exanterm sein?
Ach so, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich ein rotes Gesicht, ja.
Der Patient hat das gesagt, er kriegt so ein Flasch,
so eine schnelle Hautrötung, wenn das so heiß wird.
Okay, verstanden.
Und er hat eine Laktose in Toleranz,
die zur Methorismus und Diöre führt.
Der Patient ist seit fünf Jahren nicht raucher.
Dafür hat er 20 Jahre lang eine Schachtel geraucht,
was 20 Pakusjahre entspricht.
Und er trinkt 2, 3 Gläser Bier abends.
Drogenkonsum würde permanent.
Und in der Familie Anamnese fanden sich Ulkus Gruris beim Vater.
Deswegen hat er große Amputation.
Eine Großziehamputation, okay, ja.
Okay.
Und bei der Mutter, wir werden solle Verkrümung.
Der Patient ist ein sehr Kind.
Der Patient ist getrennt, lebt alleine, hat 3 Kinder.
Die Kinder leben mit ihrer Mutter und sie sind alle gesund.
Und er ist selbstständig und arbeitet in einer Bäckerei.
Bäckerei.
Der Patient leidet unter Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ja, gut, kann man sich vorstellen.
Gut, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Nephrolitiasis.
Und was wäre differentialdiagnostisch?
Als Fernseherdiagnose kommen Nephrolitiasis und Enteritis.
Ja, möglicherweise, ja.
Passt nicht so ganz, ja.
Systitis in Betragung.
Ja, so etwas, genau.
Wobei die Schmerzen, die er beschreibt, wenn er bei 8 von 10 ist,
das wäre ja schon ziemlich heftig.
Ja.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit ihm?
Zuerst würde ich natürlich körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde Druckschmerzen, Losslossschmerzen am Bauch kontrollieren.
Ja, was schließen Sie damit aus, was gerade gekommen ist?
Ich möchte mit diesem Entfernung,
die akute, abdomen auszuschließen,
upon the cities, parkerities, polyassistities,
und dann, ich würde,
zwei großdumige, sogenge,
anlegen, und eine gelabene Entfernung,
eine Nierenwerte,
und kleine Spulutbild,
CRP, PSG,
und dann abdomen ultrasonographie.
Ja, aber machen Sie das auch mit Technik?
Gerinux, Parameter.
Ja, ich mache jetzt noch etwas anderes außerhalb des Blutsches.
Ja, Urin Probe.
Wer macht das?
Sediment, Edith, Kosythin,
Sedimenten und Neukosythin.
Unwürdlicherweise, Kalsimi.
Ja, Kalsiuri.
Ja, und Röckenaufnahme des Apfelmans.
Ja, woauf gucken Sie beim Abdomensono?
Könnten Sie das nicht wiederholen?
Wonach schauen Sie beim Abdomensono?
Ja, bei der Sonographie
kann man vielleicht die Hürsteine sehen
und Handwerkstau.
Ganz genau.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und natürlich andere Ursae des Akkutes Apfelmans.
Alles klar. Ja, wunderbar.
Ja, gut.
Wenn wir da etwas sehen,
wie würde man dann weiterverfahren?
Weiterverfahren, ja.
Manchmal, die Niersteine
kann selbst ausgeschieden werden.
Dafür werde ich flüstern.
Genau, der kriegt das mal.
Ja, Analgesi, Schmerzmittel.
Auf alle Fälle braucht er es, ja, genau.
Antimetika würde ich geben.
Ja.
Und dann Stoßwerlin-Terapie
kann zur Verfügung stehen.
Genau.
Und Halmmeiter Schiene kann einfach da sein.
Und Neflollitiltatomi.
Genau.
Und die letzte Möglichkeit
ist die Offen-Operation.
Genau.
Das richtet sich immer nach der Größe der Steine
und auch nach der Zusammensetzung,
und dann kann man das nicht mehr zerkrümeln lassen.
Über ein Lidotriptor,
ob sie verkleiner werden können,
wenn das nicht klappt, dann muss man operieren.
Ja, super.
Dann untersuchen Sie mal Ihren Patienten weiter
und berichten Sie mir bitte hinterher,
was rausgekommen ist.
Und wie es ihm geht, den Herrn Schläfer.
Ich glaube, Sie können heute Nacht gut schlafen
und vor Ihrer Prüfung auch.
Danke schön.
Ja, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut gelaufen.
Haben Sie genau den Fall irgendwie schon mal kürzlich vor Augen gehabt?
Ich meine, das ist sogar ein Münchner Fall.
Ja, Münchner Fall.
Ich habe schon gelesen, aber zum meisten mein Erfolgschild.
Sehr geurte gemacht.
Aber es ist tatsächlich ein Münchner Fall.
Insofern fast ist es ja ganz gut.
Das ist eine Hulfige.
Ja gut, da habe ich mir nicht besonders originelles überlegt.
Schade eigentlich.
Hosen wir mal, dass der auch dran kommt, oder irgendetwas anderes Schönes,
was Sie eben so locker bewältigen.
Also ich denke mal, wirklich Sie können sehr entspannt
auf Sonnheim gucken.
Ich bin wieder heute ist, heute ist Donnerstag.
Ja, wir sind schon wieder am Ende der Woche.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist der Bedarf?
Stehen irgendwelche Prüfungen an in nächster Zeit?
Dass wir nochmal Sonnheim an Termin brauchen, Dr. Gündes?
Ich oder Andere?